so we were talking about the knicks and
the nets and then this colossal trade
came down the pike
james harden is a brooklyn net kyrie is
back from his walkabout
that's a bad real ups and downs on the
court
hardin triple doubling doing his thing
they dropped two games to the cavs
kevin first let's talk about this trade
brooklyn nets i mean they're going all
in here for sure
four first-round draft picks and four
first-round pick swaps
for james harden like what was your
initial thoughts like
from a fan perspective when that deal
went down
so i i had two thoughts that were in
opposition to each other
um the first is wow you've just given
your entire draft future like i don't
know i don't even think i've seen
like that number of picks and swaps uh
very very extreme
and you gave up two of my favorite
players from this
uh this roster jared allen and charis
levert
uh and they were they seemed like good
spirited guys young guys were upside
they both were kind of
developed by the team um so all of
that's heading
one direction but then on the other
direction you have an mvp
who wants to come play with your mvp and
uh
that's about it
didn't jared allen himself say it would
you do the trade yeah
i believe taurean prince also was asked
the same question and he said yeah i
would do the trade
so even the guys themselves in the trade
would do it and understandably so i mean
it's bittersweet
think about those guys that were part of
you know an allen and levert as part of
those fun
gritty nets teams with kenny atkinson
head coach the a couple years
back but i mean this is a trade you do
100 out of 100 times
even despite this you know kind of a up
and down start we've seen from them
uh i felt the same way it's like you
know i mean it just boils down
um that to who has the best player on
the court
if you have like the two best players on
the court or maybe three
uh if you include kyrie um so then kyrie
comes back
and i gotta say um you get these really
positive young
thunder vibes from kevin durant james
hart and then jeff green who a lot of
people forget about but he was like a
very high draft pick who played on those
thunder teams
uh and it seemed like there was some
really good chemistry and camaraderie
and they came out and like harden had
this epic debut and they were like doing
their thing and then you do have to say
that kyrie comes back
[Laughter]
and then you're looking at it you're
like um so first one of the things that
occurred to me was that if i was kevin
durant and i came to play with kyrie
irving in part because they signed
together
and then kyrie goes missing for a
significant number of games i mean i
i feel like he missed uh uh like over
five games i think um like i i had to
say
that like i feel like i might be bent
out of shape like if i signed with a
team
and uh and then like my you know my my
co-signer
um uh wasn't there and then james harden
shows up and like
you know you go way back with him that
team looked really really strong
and then kyrie coming back kyrie is
super talented
um but it it did seem like uh like there
was another adjustment
uh that has to be made for sure and i
think it's gonna take time for the
these guys all to build chemistry even
before the hardened trade it takes time
i mean they started nine and eight to
twenty ten eleven miami heat
started nine and eight and sometimes
you're gonna lose or go through you know
some bumps before you
become the team that you you have the
potential to be and with this nets team
with kyrie taking that time off for
personal reasons he stated that he you
know didn't really
want to get into i'm sure that is tough
you know when that whole team is bought
in and sacrificing in their own
respective ways
um but ultimately katie and kyrie the
fact those guys
chose to play together you know says a
lot about their relationship and their
ability to to get through any difficult
times and i think the fact that harden
wanted to go there
and his relationship with kd kde is
going to serve as kind of i think that
like connective glue
on the team he's not necessarily like a
traditional you know
throwback leader he's not like a guy who
yells at people like michael jordan he's
not the lebron type of leader but
for this team a star power team i think
kd can keep these
guys together through a time like this
and losing two games versus cleveland
this kind of like this feels like a
wake-up call
in some ways because you got the cavs
that like this team just fights so
hard every guy on that roster is trying
everything they can to win games and
and steve nash said after i think
friday's game he's like you know we
we're not a defensive team
we have to you know overcome that
through effort and hard work and
communication and
you know maybe for the nets it could be
a good thing for them to drop some of
these games here
because it's going to show the amount of
effort they get to put into the
defensive end they can't just outscore
everybody
even though they're going to put up a
lot of points and that's what they're
going to really you know win or lose
with this scoring but
their defense does need to be better and
that's my concern with them for sure
so so you say 100 times out of 100 you
make this trade
and i agree um you know they're in it to
win it
now it's clear like it's it's title
contention or bust
which i appreciate because i i think
that any time a team goes for it in this
way you kind of have to give them credit
uh but you know i think
maximizing your chances of winning a
title when you're close to it
is the right thing to do and a lot of
teams um
maybe don't take that level of uh
commitment or investment so so you do it
fantastic um you do have some concerns i
agree and
like the cavs uh games sort of spoke to
it where
you look at the roster and steve nash
said there's not a defensive roster
um so even though you make the trade
a hundred times out of 100 times kevin
and you were very optimistic about the
nets pre-trade you were like look these
guys
could could uh win the east and make it
to the finals and play probably the
lakers
look at this stuff um uh
you feel the same way uh now having uh
gotten a little bit more
like uh exposure to them on the court
definitely and and you know i think that
bucks game the game they won
granted you know no kyrie i feel like
that game showed the upside here
because this team like you know their
offense has the potential to be like an
all-time
offense like when have we ever seen
three creative genius scorers
you know with their level of talent be
put together on the same roster like
they can play off ball they've played
with other stars in their past
katie obviously you mentioned playing
with hard and prior you know kyrie
playing with
lebron and katie going to golden state
all the stars you know hard and play
within houston
these guys can can make things work and
you guys like joe harris
who is just going to get countless open
shots and he doesn't need to be open to
drain threes this offense is going to be
ridiculous
and with their defense you know when it
comes to wanting to do this trade 100
times out of 100 you raise your ceiling
and you probably
you know make your defense worse but
it's not like
kyrie in some of those finals runs with
the cavs didn't show that when he's
really given a hundred percent that he
can be a really good defensive player at
the guard spot for you it's not like kd
at his peak you know is not one of the
greatest defenders we haven't seen when
he was playing the five for the warriors
he can really
elevate his play and harden once a guy
who people rip for playing poor defense
has become a really solid defender he's
especially like good on switches against
some bigger guys so
the nets like to me i look at that team
and it's like they need help around the
edges
with some of their other winged uh
players with depth you know finding
another big they just sign pel
who should help a little bit you know
behind deandre jordan but finding one
more guy
to me can help raise the floor
of the team like it's a defensive unit
and you know their ceiling is not just
you know
one finals it's multiple and obviously
it's hard to do that and need a lot of
luck along the way too but
having these guys together like could
just lead to some obscene offense with
still pretty good defense with the right
guys around them
are there any available role players
because i know there's some free agents
floating around too
like it like that you think the nets are
either are looking at or should look at
you know i had a conversation with an
exec this week about that and because we
were talking about the net so i was like
who do you think they would look for
who are the guys out there and what they
said to me was this
because of the league's new rules with
the playing tournament which means
so normally in the nba playoffs eight
teams in each conference 16 total make
the postseason
this year there will be the seven eight
nine and ten seed
that get to play multiple games for the
7 and 8 spot
and the fact that you have more teams
that have a chance to get that 10 spot
that means more teams have reason to win
less reason to let go of players players
have more reason to be bought in and
so on and so forth which could mean that
there's not going to be a lot of players
available for a team like the nets
to go out there and get like we saw the
lakers get with markeith morris last
year
like we've seen with other you know
teams with championship popes
in the past because you know people
around the people around the league say
the nets are hoping
that andre drummond the cavs center gets
bought out oh my gosh
that's what people say they're hoping
for but that's unlikely like it's just
it's so unlikely because cleveland's in
it you know they're in it
partially because they're pretty good
but also because they have more playoff
spots to get in
you know so we might not see a lot of
options out there
which is you know i'm not really
answering your question but like i don't
know if there will be many options this
could be a really limited buyout period
and like they don't have any picks so
there's not much they can trade to
actually
get somebody in return maybe a jj redick
somebody like that from the pelicans
that's one name i'm serious like jj iraq
is one name i'll throw out there
jj can stroke some threes for you that
would be a great put jj
i mean that would be incredible but like
i feel like jj is way out of their reach
i i
was like thinking of folks that you know
might actually be available
pelicans are bad right now they were bad
really struggling
but they need more more jj's not fewer
jj's i mean
it's like shooting you're right though i
will say this jj a free agent this
coming off season
maybe the pelicans would think let's get
something you know
in return jj's from really not from
brooklyn but lives in brooklyn with his
family would make sense
you know to why you're planting some
seeds well so i mean when i think about
the nets too though it's like i feel
like
at least this is like the thinking you
have so you've got
uh the three stars joe harris deandre
jordan
um and like what you think is you need
some gritty role players who'll just go
out there
and throw their bodies around and pass
the ball to one of the three stars
get out of the way yeah like you know
you also got jeff green who
you know i think is going to be like
hugely important on this team actually
um and and so then i like i look up and
i'm just like who the heck did they get
that kind of fits that gritty
role-playing mold he'll just like do his
thing and like you know
like like not um like i mean and this is
just me throwing something out there
this probably doesn't fit but like a pj
tucker type just going like
that's a good one pj tucker is a great
great example of what they should be
going for because then like you can play
him
with jeff green and play that s or and
kevin durant have switch ability
and still have really good defense out
on the court that makes perfect sense
and
you know i reported on the ringer a
couple weeks back that you know the
demand for pj tucker
sounds like three second round draft
picks which
doesn't sound like a lot but you know
there are a lot of people around the
league who think it is because he's 35
years old because he's gonna be a free
agent this offseason
and because you know you know outside of
the offense without hardin let's see
what he looks like
granted if he were going to brooklyn he
would be with hardin again and be with
other stars and playing off of them so
that guy that makes perfect sense for
the nets i like that idea i think him or
reddick or both
how about that i'm just thinking about
like also like the street freight agents
who are like out there
still like uh like iman shumpert as an
example like just throw shumpert out
there and have him like you know
jamal crawford guys like that bring back
jabal crawford why not
exactly i mean it's true there are there
are some solid vets out there that could
be worth an
addition but uh ultimately like the
norvel pell signing is sort of along the
lines of what you're saying
that it is you know and you know we'll
see if he sticks or not he was pretty
good with philly
last year in a real limited role uh and
when other guys were out but
you know that's what we're probably
looking at in all likelihood for the
nets
in terms of what they can add but maybe
like i said like a reddick or maybe a pj
tucker one of those
guys could pop up um but we'll see how
the market develops it could be a weird
year with trades in the buyout market
man if they were to get drummond i mean
that would be like freaking epic
you know i mean like that's way beyond
i don't see it happen personally but i
mean it's just you know people are on
the like say the nets
are hoping he gets bought out which
we'll see because his trade market
when he was with detroit was so limited
they had a hard time finding anybody
that would take him
and it's not like even though he's
having a solid season much would change
there
but i i do think i do think that there
would be enough interest that one team
would at least take him on
for the rest of the season we wouldn't
see a bio but who knows who knows
crazier things have happened in the nba
that's for sure
including james harden getting paired
with kevin durant and kyrie irving
so i'd say like the big thing a lot of
us are thinking is that this team seems
like a
chemistry um exerciser experiment now
conventional wisdom is that if you have
three stars one of them needs to
sacrifice a bit
um and and it feels like kyrie is the
natural candidate to sacrifice somehow
maybe because of um hardin and duran's
pre-existing relationship or like his
relative um
you know uh like size or or something
like for whatever reason it just feels
like that they're mvp
and then it also feels like um like this
like the the chemistry element is going
to be key and that steve nash
is like the obviously the the um
key figure in trying to manage that
chemistry like am i the only person who
feels like these two things
no i mean it's definitely a big
experiment here
and you know everything i said earlier
about these guys
they they could sacrifice and they can't
fit because they have in the past
it doesn't mean it would work you know
circumstances change relationships
change and
and maybe the mix just doesn't work you
know maybe they lose and these guys
clash who knows what the future brings
but
you know it's still at the end of the
day it's 100 everything you're saying
that
putting these level of stars together
who you know
are often isolationists you know you've
given the ball they run a pick and roll
the defense switches and then they are
on an island it's one on one it's like
at the park
and that that can be hard sometimes it
can feel like your turn my turn
and in terms of you know now it's
katie's turn now it's kyrie's turn now
it's hardened turn
and sometimes that can leave this lead
to stagnant offense but ultimately
i feel like james harden when he was in
houston
the last you know four or five years he
became that you know iso player that guy
who's
you know dominating the ball but when he
was in okc
he could run off screens and he could
run off of handoffs and not have the
ball in his hands
and still be a threat and katie himself
went to golden state improved as a
passer became a guy who played even more
off ball than he did in okc
i feel like those guys have shown a
willingness to do that
when it comes to competing for
championships and that they can do it
again here and ultimately with brooklyn
and steve nash especially it's gonna be
on him as the head coach and that whole
coaching staff
to put these players in positions to
succeed and then for the players to play
with the effort necessarily
necessary on defense to complement what
will be a high scoring offense like this
offense is going to
get up put up points like it's
up to the stars to bring in that
defensive mindset to me more so than the
offensive sacrifice like they get to be
the leaders of the defense and
we'll see i mean it's a long season but
i think they can
interesting um it's so it's like a
defensive sacrifice more than an
offensive sacrifice that you think it's
being called for i think steve nash
might agree with you
i mean it's it's like the type of thing
where let's say you're not getting you
know
x amount of possessions per game 30
possessions instead you're getting 20.
you get to put that energy you would put
into those extra 10 possessions
into defense you know it that's what
needs to happen
and kyrie i'll say this like before his
hiatus away from the court
when he opened the season the first
couple games he was really busting his
butt on defense
he was setting a tone for the team and
it looked like playoff kyrie and
i don't expect that over the full
regular season he's probably gonna coast
at certain points as you should when you
might
be playing into the finals but if he's
able to turn
back to that level in the playoffs like
we've seen him do in the past
i have a hard time seeing anybody
beating the nets in the eastern
conference like the bucks have too many
holes
some of these other teams have so many
holes i feel like
it could be competitive against the
celtics it could be competitive against
the bucks and
you know the sixers but i still feel
like the nets have higher upside
um than any of these teams wow you heard
it here
everyone kevin o'connor is picking the
most fascinating team
go brooklyn go steve nash i mean i've
got a i mean i'm a fan of a lot of folks
associated with this team
i want steve nash to succeed um so
i hope you are right
you